according to the former Inca Empire of
eastern South America in the most
ancient of times the earth was covered
in darkness then out of a lake called
kala su you the god kontiki baracoa
emerged bringing with him human beings
following this kontiki created the Sun
the moon and the stars to light the
world out of the great rocks kontiki
fashioned more human beings including
women who were already pregnant sending
them into every corner of the world over
time however the humans forgot Khan's
goodness to them and rebelled and so he
punished them by stopping the rainfall
and the humans were forced to work hard
scrounging what little water they could
find from the drying riverbeds however
the newly formed God pachacamac came and
drove Caan out changing his people into
monkeys after which Patric amok took
over the earth and made the ancestors of
human beings this creation myth like so
many others tries to answer the
questions that we all ask where did we
come from why are we here and are we
meant for something greater
while much of the universe's origin is
shrouded in mystery what we do know is
that at the beginning of all things
there was only the presence representing
the God of judeo-christianity the
presence was represented in four primary
forms to voice allowing the presence to
communicate the hand allowing the
presence to create and the source
allowing the presence to derive all
things with the hand and the source the
presence craft the source wall as a
barrier in order to confine the infinite
power of the source itself within the
wall the presence constructed the
multiverse a vast series of universes
coexisting in parallel from this vast
expanse of nothingness our universe saw
its first signs of life with the endless
for beings representing the four
elements of all creation the first and
oldest of these was destiny who
chronicled all events from the formation
of the multiverse to its guaranteed end
following this death and dream emerged
as well as destruction whose arrival
coincided with the emergence of the
first sentient races
after this the presence began to shape
and develop heaven beginning with the
seven Archangels originally consisting
of Lucifer Yuri Oh Raphael Michael
seroquel Gabriel and ragga all following
their creation the presence introduced
angels for the purpose of delivering
messages accompanying the lonely and
granting protection while this time in
heaven served as paradise within a
subject of his populous resentment was
groomed led by the Archangel Lucifer
whose pride and self-importance seized
control he alongside one-third of the
angelic population engaged in a
rebellion against the presence and in
turn were cast out of heaven I can find
a Hell initiating an ethereal war which
would rage until the end of time within
the multiverse and in a universe far
from our own life was beginning to bloom
originating with a god world at the
center of all things
these first gods were beings of enormous
power and glory as well as cultural and
scientific refinement relying on the
prayers of their subjects for sustenance
the old gods cared little about their
people often leading prayers unanswered
following this and around five billion
years ago much like Lucifer immortal
name you SAS began scattering doubt
among the old gods regarding their
strength towards one another sowing the
seeds of conflict after countless eons
of unbridled peace the world of the old
gods was twenty part by war preying on
the dead and consuming their energies
the actions of uc's hats were opposed by
his brother Isaiah absorbing the
energies from the god of the sky
yucks fasts and Isaiah engaged in a
battle but found themselves equally
matched laying waste to God world and
cracking the planet and to the effect of
this act sent a wave of cosmic energy
radiating throughout the multiverse
planting the seeds that would give rise
to the gods of various cultures
turning their attention to the remnants
of God world huge SAS christened himself
Darkseid and use one half of the planets
remnants to form apocalypse while Isaiah
became high father using the other half
to form new Genesis
well the remainder of the surviving
population will be split among these two
territories and form the armies of the
respective rulers within our universe
the first sentient race was reaching
perfection on the planet Malta's around
five billion years prior to the war of
the old gods the first sentient beings
emerged as a Malthusians born from
single-celled creatures which evolved
into multi-celled creatures known as
micro colonies the first organisms
bonded themselves to primitive
Malthusians that allowed them to
maintain an evolutionary edge over all
other creatures slowly transforming into
humanoids the Malthusians quickly became
the dominant life force on their planet
turning their attention towards the
early development of science and
technology like many tribes and their
infancy however the Malthusians were not
without their darker side with different
groups forming in each one worshiping
its own beating the Malthusians found
themselves in a state of civil war as
each tribe had attempted to secure its
position as ruler of the world during
this time and in an act of desperation
one of the tribes released a plague upon
the planet that cut a swath through
their population by disrupting and
destroying the symbiotic relationship of
the mountains and the micro colonies the
remaining Malthusian student discovered
that only those in highly populated
areas were affected while those in rural
areas were not coming to the realization
of a plague spread through physical
contact the plague was cured in all
forms of touch were outlawed leading the
mountains to begin genetically
engineering their offspring using this
newfound method of reproduction as a
means to perfect their race the
mountains experienced an age of
enlightenment and dowing themselves with
a myriad of powers including telepathy
telekinesis and the ability to warp the
very structure of their own world for a
thousand years the Malthusians continued
to evolve and grow with each generation
experiencing enhancements to their own
longevity on the other hand because
children being young and careless fail
to understand the responsibility that
came with their gifts the Malthusians
experienced a conflict between their
youth and their elders leading the group
to eliminate reproduction in its
entirety owing to the recklessness that
comes with a lack of maturity
following this and during an unknown
time in their history after pushing the
limits of science a Malthusian woman
named Kai Lala discovered the ability to
tap into the emotional spectrum where
some say that the emotional spectrum
itself is the source of all life
others say came into existence when the
first beings experienced their first
emotions whether this is true was
unknown but what is known is that while
this lone mountains ability to access
this force was primitive a time was
rapidly approaching when the Malthusians
would put the concept to use within the
Empire of mountains and as part of their
sign to the expeditionary force was
Crona obsessed with seeing the origin of
the universe
crota violated the Malthusian sacred
laws and use their instruments of
technology to achieve his goal
witnessing the hand of the presence as
it gave birth to all things crona's
actions opened a rift in space-time
allowing the time-traveller volthoom to
enter into the past as a being of human
heritage volthoom was very familiar with
the emotional spectrum and after
tutoring the Malthusians to harness the
full capabilities of his power was
offered a position among their ranks as
the first Lantern wielding the Nayan
militant power of the full spectrum
volthoom
did not hail from humble beginnings
instead like Lucifer and Darkseid his
pride arrogance and cruelty were drawn
to the surface through his use of
absolute power and his desire to toy
with the souls of mortal men abandoning
their role as Malthusians and taking up
their place on OA the mouse ujin's in
prison both foo assigning a handful of
their own to serve as custodians for all
eternity writing both zoom out of their
records
the remaining Owens christened
themselves guardians of the universe and
went forward designing an engineering a
method to keep the universe safe from
evil traveling outside of our universe
because all things exist in balance for
every end there must be a Yang and if
our universe was composed a positive
matter there must also be a universe
composed of antimatter functioning in a
manner almost identical to our own the
antimatter universe contained its own
fledgling civilizations each attempting
to understand its place in the
antimatter universe at the same time and
much like Crona a scientific Explorer
Moebius from a plant accord look to
witness the creation of the antimatter
universe designing a chair to serve the
purposes both chronicler of his exploits
and witness to all things presently
happening mobius peered into the past
and advertently forming the anti-life
equation which allowed him to bend the
will of all sentient beings falling into
a sleep lasting three billion years
faded would seem is not without a sense
of humor maintaining balance the
transition of mobius from mortal to
anti-monitor
resulted in our universe unleashing a
counterbalance and the form of the
monitor while these two beings spent
eons in slumber the universe continued
to unfold returning to OA the guardians
of the universe begun work on creating a
mechanical force known as the Manhunters
tasked with policing and ensuring the
safety of the universe the Guardians
planted within the robots a singular
mantra no man escapes the Manhunters
however in their hubris the Guardians
fail to understand the full gamut of
their work and after evolving to the
point of becoming self-aware the
Manhunters rebelled initiating a
thousand-year war the conflict between
the guardians of the Manhunters
stretched the cosmos impacting some
fifty million worlds while the guardians
did what they could to minimize the
collateral damage within Sector six five
seven on the planet we mute the actions
of the Manhunters would send a singular
being over the edge and in his bloodlust
would become the first being outside of
the Owens and cells to tap into the
emotional spectrum